[Music]
hey guys
it's quinn the youtube algorithm totally
ignores my videos sometimes
and you can really help out just by
clicking the like button thanks guys
the matriarchal order known as the benny
jesuit sisterhood
is one of the most powerful groups to
ever exist in the dune universe
for thousands of years this organization
of selectively bred
and highly trained women maneuvers its
way through the various political
structures which rise and fall
throughout the duration of the dune saga
as time changes so does the motivation
of the mini jesuit
their pragmatism is in fact one of their
greatest assets
the mini jesuit operated in block
structure the mother superior gave the
commands
but each sister would only receive the
information necessary to the task
for which she was assigned the
sisterhood had operated in this fashion
for thousands of years
and only had made minor alterations to
this structure
its effectiveness had been tried and
tested
many jesuit divisions were cut by hard
vertical and horizontal barriers
divided into isolated groups that
converged to a single command
only here at the top duties for which
reed assigned
roles were conducted within separated
cells
active participants within a cell did
not know their contemporaries within
other parallel cells
the mini jesuit schools were created
during the events following the machine
crusade
also known as the butlerian jihad which
freed mankind from human lead
but machine enforced slavery the bini
jesuit trained its students in
psychology
history science they taught special
techniques which provided sisters with
almost superhuman abilities
such as their prana bendu techniques
which allowed them to control their body
chemistry on a molecular level
because of this a trained sister was
immune to most poisons
and if she so chose could slow her own
aging process down to a near halt
creating seeming immortality though this
was strictly forbidden by the sisterhood
they also were taught a special kind of
martial arts known as the weirding way
in close quarters the weirding way
allowed the mini jesuit to maneuver
their bodies
with such speed and grace that it could
be mistaken easily for teleportation
certain vinny jesuit sisters could also
become truth-savers
because of the benny jesuit ability to
read the most delicate of human minutia
certain sisters can develop the ability
to always be able to detect when a lie
is told
if the sister of the benny jesuit
reaches a certain level
then they may be allowed to take the
truthsayer drug and
undergo the spice agony which would
awaken her full bini jesuit powers
she would become a reverend mother the
truthsayer drug
is deadly if a sister can consume the
drug and use her bini jesuit powers to
nullify it
the agony of the ordeal will unlock her
genetic memory
her memories of her maternal ancestors
for some reason no sisters were ever
able to unlock the paternal half of
these memories
because of this fact for many eons the
beni jesuit plan centered around the
creation of the quizets hadirak
he would be a man who could be trained
in the beni jesuit way
and tested as a reverend mother would be
if he could endure
the spice agony he would unlock both the
maternal and the paternal sides of his
ancestral memory
the quiz that's had a wreck would also
be bred for prescience
so he would have the ability to predict
future events similar to guild
navigators
but in a much more refined manner many
men had been tested in the way of
reverend mothers
but none had survived yet
there is a place where no truth sayer
can see we are
repelled by it terrorized
it is said a man will come one day and
find in the gift of the drug his
inward eye he will look where we cannot
into both feminine and masculine past
your quizadz herrera yes
the one who can be in many places at
once the quizzes had iraq
many men have tried the drug so many
but none has succeeded they tried and
failed
all of them oh no she shook her head
they tried and died for many generations
the sisterhood had used the great houses
to breathe their quizzes cataract into
existence
all their previous attempts had failed
but with the benny jesuit lady jessica's
joining to the house of treaties
they were closer than ever jessica had
been instructed to bear only daughters
to the duke later atreides
it was one of the many powers of the
benny jesuit sisters to choose the sex
of their child
the mini jesuit would then breed the
atreides daughter to a harkonnen's son
the result would be the quizets hedorak
but ultimately jessica's love for the
duke
would cause her to defy her sisterhood
and instead first conceive a son
paul atreides and hoping that he could
be the quizzette's hedorah
she trained him in the mini jesuit way
paul was eventually tested and he proved
to possess the powers of the foretold
benny jesuit quiz attirat
but when he was called to serve the
sisterhood he refused
if jessica had obeyed the orders of her
sisterhood
the heir of the harkonnen and atreides
merging would have been subjected to
precise
benny jesuit conditioning he would be a
creature of the sisterhood
easily maneuvered by them or so they
believed
but because of jessica's disobedience
the quizatz hadirak was raised beyond
bini jesuit control
a generation too soon influenced by
outside forces such as his atreides
morality
and minta training the bini jesuit had
no power over paul
you could argue that the benny jessup
mistake was believing that they would be
able to control a being possessing
such power in the first place if a being
has the power to see the possible
futures of mankind
and therefore become the fulcrum by
which the fate of the universe turns
then how can anyone ever hope to bring
that being under its power
the benny jesuit also failed in assuming
that an essential human
instinct the biological drive for
intimate companionship
could be fully repressed jessica's love
for the duke plato
ultimately overcame all of her benny
jesuit conditioning
it would have been wise of the benny
jesuit to monitor this aspect
of human nature among its students more
effectively
the bini jesuit would never forget the
actions of lady jessica
and they fear the creation of another
quizet's hedorah
recognizing that the threat such a being
possesses to the human universe
is too great to risk thank you guys for
watching
make sure you like and subscribe for
more science fiction videos
you